les négociateurs russes sont arrivés à
istanbul dans l'après midi de lundi la
nouvelle session de pourparlers avec les
ukrainiens doit s'ouvrir ce mardi mais
pour ce qui est d'une rencontre au
sommet entre les deux présidents russe
et ukrainien que volodymyr et l'ins qui
appelle de ses voeux moscou sens opposé
une fin de non-recevoir définitive
repousse l'échéance
sergueï lavrov estime qu'un tel
entretien serait prématuré en cela dit
il a dit qu'il ne refuserai jamais
droite président
le conflit à l'intérieur de l'ukraine
school depuis si longtemps des années
beaucoup de problèmes se sont accumulés
cause se rencontrer et se dire qu'est ce
que tu penses je pense qu'elle juge trop
petit
le chef de la diplomatie russe
conditionne aussi cette rencontre à la
satisfaction des exigences de moscou
dans les négociations la russie réclame
notamment la démilitarisation et la
neutralité de l'ukraine se qualifie de
dénazification du pays ainsi que la
reconnaissance par kiev de l'annexion de
la crimée par la russie en 2014 ou
encore l'indépendance des républiques
pro-russe du donbass
quelques heures avant côté ukrainien
volodimir et l'ins qui s'était dit prêt
à des compromis et pas des moindres ya
panier moi je comprends qu'il est
impossible de forcer complètement là
réussi à quitter le territoire ukrainien
cela conduirait à la troisième guerre
mondiale
je le comprends et c'est pourquoi je
parle d'un compromis risque de se
retourner là où tout a commencé et
ensuite nous essaierons de résoudre le
problème du dombass la question
compliquée du dombass
l'ukraine se dit aussi prête à un
compromis sur la question de sa non
adhésion à l'otan mais exige un cessez
le feu immédiat et le retrait des
troupes russes une précédente séance de
négociations avaient déjà eu lieu le 10
mars en turquie à antalya au niveau des
ministres des affaires étrangères elle
n'avait débouché sur aucune avancée
concrète